welcome everybody to uh the microsoft
research summit
the um responsible ai track and right
now the panel entitled content
moderation beyond the ban
reducing borderline toxic misleading and
low quality content
my name is charlton gillespie i'm a
senior principal researcher at microsoft
research in the new england lab
and i've co-organized this panel with
zoe darmay zoe durmay is currently
at google as a i wrote this down as a
senior manager in public policy and
global affairs handling search
and i want to tell you a bit about the
panel and what we're going to talk about
today and then i'll introduce our three
speakers hopefully we'll have a chance
to hear from them and then also uh open
up a discussion
uh let me start by saying that um we're
thinking about content moderation here
and it's been
important and amazing to see that
content moderation has grown as a public
discussion we pay more attention to it
it's sometimes on the front page of the
newspaper it's a discussion in
legislative corners and academic corners
and this is phenomenal but one thing
that zoe and i were noticing and wanted
to talk with some experts about is that
we tend to focus um very exclusively on
the question of removal
so the removal of content things that
get deleted and the removal of users
people who get banned
and this is an important part of what
social media platforms do but it's not
the only thing in fact
we think there is a whole set of tactics
and techniques that platforms often use
when they're trying to deal with
misinformation harassment threats of
violence terrorism pornography you name
it
that don't look like removal and
suspension
and then in fact
this array of tactics are quite
important and perhaps growing in
importance
so the idea of this panel is to sort of
dedicate some time to think about those
tactics bring them up in the forefront
and really try to bring an
interdisciplinary lens to what are these
tactics how do they work what are their
implications
how effective might they be what kind of
problems do they raise and how do we go
forward
thinking about content moderation in a
way that includes these tactics and
recognizes their growing importance
so eric goldman wrote an excellent paper
called content moderation remedies and
he was making a similar point that if we
set aside the question of removal
there's a whole set of other tactics
that platforms have been using for quite
a long time not just theoretical but
are in practice
let me give you a few examples this is
not an exhaustive list and more may come
up as we're talking about it um but
think back to when we were debating
whether
twitter and other platforms should be
putting fact check messages or warnings
on president trump's tweets other
political figures the idea of putting a
fact check or a warning is a tactic that
doesn't remove the tweet necessarily but
changes where it's going to go and how
people understand it
youtube has been playing around with
nudging commenters who might be writing
something that could be harassing or
could be violent saying are you sure you
want to post this comment
in order to sort of keep discussion
respectful doesn't prevent someone from
doing it but maybe it's going to nudge
or change
the tendency to do so uh reddit as a
platform has been playing around with a
technique called quarantining where
whole areas whole subreddits on topics
that have indicated that they uh are are
tend to be places full of misinformation
or or violence
can be sort of set aside they still
exist but the posts they write won't
show up on the front page there's a
warning before you enter them and their
limits on how they can earn money
we've seen growing efforts to reduce the
visibility of misinformation we're
seeing a lot of platforms doing that
that can mean
taking certain kinds of borderline
content and removing it from
recommendations recommending it less
leaving it out of search results so
they're still there but they don't
circulate quite as widely
we're seeing this especially around
pandemic and vaccine misinformation but
not exclusively
instagram recently introduced a
sensitive content control letting users
decide how much and how racy the content
they would see would show up in their
recommendations and those settings were
based on the idea that you might want to
see more of it you might want to see
less of it and you could sort of adjust
that and other platforms are playing
with kind of design techniques to give
users different ways to calibrate that
content and recently uh very recently in
the wall street journal we've had
revelations about
facebook and a program they called
xcheck that was setting aside many users
who were public figures
uh people who might be sort of like pr
issues people who had prominent
followings to handle them differently
right uh to handle them uh in a
different process so sort of whole
shadow structures of processes that
might not look like your traditional
kind of do you take it down do you
remove the user
and we think that these tactics are
growing in prominence and are under
attended to because we tend to discuss
the things that look like censorship
because we worry the most about content
that's removed or content people that
are kicked off
because that triggers a whole lot of
questions about free speech and
journalism and bias and politics
and they're also extremely hard to study
it's hard to know when these tactics are
being introduced it's hard to know how
much a video has been reduced or how far
a tweet would have gone otherwise
and so these are very difficult things
for us to consider and things for us to
to research
so the idea of this panel again is to
look beyond the band to think about
these tactics as a category
across many platforms some that have
been placed for a long time some that
are showing up
quite recently why do these tactics
matter how do they work
what are the different ways of thinking
about the logics behind them and the
whole sort of moderation ecosystem
and what are the implications of these
approaches for the platforms for the
users for possible regulation for the
future of online discourse
okay so that's a quick introduction but
i'm sure that uh you'll learn more about
those types as we begin to discuss how
we should think about them
so let me introduce the rest of our
panel so we're going to hear first from
charlotte wellner charlotte wellner is
the director of the trust and safety
professional association after having
spent many years uh working first for
facebook and then for pinterest
then we'll hear from ryan kayla
ryankillo is a professor
in the school of law at the university
of washington
and then finally we'll hear from sarita
uh shainabak who is an associate
professor in the school of information
uh at the university of michigan and
then we'll have some q a from zoe and
myself and uh see what we can figure out
i want to highlight the fact that we
very deliberately wanted to get some
some very different perspectives here an
industry perspective a legal perspective
a design perspective a sociological
perspective these problems require this
kind of questioning
and they touch on these issues
okay so uh so let's start with charlotte
um thank you so much for being here so
we know that content moderation is a
messy uh project uh for platforms large
and small doing all sorts of kind of
things these tactics these um reduction
tactics and filtering tactics and
labeling tactics the ones that go beyond
removal um are they as messy are they a
solution to the mess how are you
thinking about them and how do you think
platforms are thinking about them
absolutely um
first i would say in the words of marie
kondo i love maths
and i think that to be in content
moderation in a way you gotta love maths
because the reality is
life is messy right humans are messy and
so there is no one clear answer on the
question of content moderation where
it's like ah this is the the unmessy way
to do it um you're always going to be
thinking about trade-offs and a lot of
the way we think about our work is in
terms of trade-offs if there were one
right answer that everyone could do
everyone be doing it right instead what
you're often trying to do is is think
through okay we have a few
sometimes all you have is bad choices
but usually you have a few sort of
mediocre choices and you're going to
have to figure out what are the outcomes
that we're probably going to see here
and
are we willing to accept those outcomes
are we going to get to a better place
sort of pursuing those so even thinking
through the list of things that that you
had sort of introduced us with these
tactics
um
i think it could be useful to talk about
you know in in the seat of a content
moderator how were you thinking about
the tools that you have in your tool kit
and i think first and foremost in
content moderation mostly what we want
to do is prevent problems to begin with
uh and so that's where when you look at
tools like the be respectful nudges
right when youtube's like hey you know
remember be respectful when you're
talking to people uh twitter has this
feature that i run into all the time
where you go to retweet something it's
like do you want to read the article
first um yeah a next door if you post
anything about covid like where can you
get a covet test there's a little pop-up
thing like remember a lot of
misinformation are on there about covert
are you sure you want to post this be
thinking about how you're communicating
with your community and the idea with
all of those is to help uh help a user
moderate themselves and
that's a choice that takes you know
takes obviously some burden
operationally off of your team but it
allows people to be in charge of their
own content allows people to make
choices about you know the way they
represent themselves online and that in
a lot of ways is our ideal in a content
moderation world um you might also be
looking at you know sort of these these
medium
sort of medium level decisions for
content where you're trying to get a
faster resolution for a user so often
when people think about content
moderation they're like ah yes content
moderation someone reports it and then
someone looks at it and it's up or it's
down right and even if that were all the
content moderation we were talking about
you're waiting right that user is
waiting for an answer on their report
the person who's had their content
reported is waiting for a decision on
whether their content is going to exist
or not and so
a lot of those you know sort of uh in
sort of intermediate decisions that
we're talking about today are ways to
help either you know the reporting user
or you know the accused user or the
public sort of on your platform at large
feel some sense of more immediate
resolution even if it's temporary so
those are things you might see like when
you report something it gets hidden
maybe it gets hidden for you maybe it's
hidden for everybody until someone
reviews it right there's sort of a
set of levers you can pull there as a
content moderator um the fact checks the
quarantines right
those are often you know not necessarily
doing a lot they're not removing the
content but they're showing your
community hey we're on it right we've
noticed we've heard what you're telling
us and we are you know monitoring the
situation here's what you need to know
so having that visible accountability is
a content moderation choice that is not
it's up or it's down and again i think
helps the community often feel like
they've got some sense of control or
they're being listened to or they have
you know the ability to participate in
that process
um you do a lot of things like uh you're
focused on de-emphasizing disruptive
content you know you'd mentioned
low-quality content i think we all have
a debate about like what constitutes low
quality um but you see this with spam
right one of the things that in general
has been very uncontroversial in our
world is you know either deleting spam
or often sort of quarantining or
demoting spam
and a lot of people most people maybe
not spammers but most people really like
that that's a good choice even though
that is often a little imprecise it's
often not that transparent to the end
user because we're able to determine
through a series of metrics we may
discuss a little bit later we're able to
determine that that's low quality
content
um
i think
increasingly what we're seeing is
platforms
really thinking through what it means to
recommend content and that's something i
hope we can talk a lot about with serena
and ryan um with you because
i think historically
recommendations i think are viewed as
like oh this is like content that
performs well and so we're going to be
pushing this out it's like ah yeah this
is like you know you're going to get
really a lot of engagement or whatever
it is um i know certainly when i was
working at pinterest i was a pinterest
from 2013 to
the end of 2020. we thought a lot about
recommendations because we sort of felt
like well recommendations means we think
this is great and are recommending it to
you right there's the sense of agency
and so
um you know that's that's really an
interesting lever for folks to pull when
they're like okay it's not just that
it's up or it's down it's like do we
think it's good and you should have more
of it right um there's a lot of uh
interesting
sort of decisions to be made along that
spectrum that increasingly content
moderation teams are part of either in
labeling that data we're actually making
some of those decisions
and then finally and then we'll really
get into it um i think there is
there's a really important role for
these intermediate solutions when you
just don't know the answer uh and that
is extremely common for a lot of things
um and you need
you need to make a decision right
content moderators don't have an option
to just say well
i don't know therefore nothing happens
right even doing nothing with a piece of
content is making a choice and an
example i'd give here is actually a lot
of the different types of decisions
we're seeing on ivermectin um so it's
you know september of 2021 and different
platforms are making a lot of different
choices and ivermectin is the substance
where
a lot of folks are trying to use it to
treat copin 19
that may not be the best medical
decision some platforms have gone right
out and said nope no ivormectin anywhere
we ban all of it ivermectin is a real
medical
substance or it's real pharmaceutical
it's used in veterinary context it's
used in human context it's one of the
only treatments we have a river
blindness so some platforms are saying
well you know maybe we don't ban it
overall but we have to
i apparently there's a platform where
it's asking you to upload a picture of
you and your horse i don't know right
there are all these decisions that
people have to make
on the up or down where there really are
these real world consequences and so i
think you know in in situations where
the information is changing fast or the
information is something we just can't
know
that's where this intermediate road
becomes really interesting
ryan um thank you for being here so i
so we can hear this like the way that
these techniques might sort of intervene
at the right moment they might sort of
uh
involve themselves a different way i
i've heard you write about incentives
thinking about content moderation as a
kind of incentive process how did these
tactics not the removal but these other
ones
how do they work as incentives do they
work instead of how do we think about
that
sure well um
so i i am one of the co-pis at a center
here at the university of washington
called the center for an informed public
and what we do is we study and try to
come up with techniques to resist
misinformation
and we span multiple different
disciplines
so i'm writing this essay with my my
colleagues
emma spiro and keith starboard and jevin
west
and chris coward in which we're drawing
a few distinctions about misinformation
that i think will be instructive here
and the first is simply the distinction
between misinformation and
disinformation where misinformation
refers to just kind of getting something
wrong
just innocently maybe maybe not but the
idea is you're just saying something
incorrect
i've done that myself many people have
done that right disinformation is
uh pardon the pun um about it about the
about horses but a horse of a different
color because you know it's actually a
strategic
campaign
right that has both
um elements of misinformation elements
of of lies and and falsities and
misleading statements um but it also has
as part of a whole campaign a lot of
truth and a lot of opinion
and why does that matter from an
intervention perspective well because
you know if you think about the themes
of sort of responsible artificial
intelligence i mean there may be things
that machine learning can do about
individual pieces of content so for
example an ai system may be able to
figure out the context in which
mentioning this drug is okay and the one
over here when it's not and when it's
going to be misleading
but ai is not going to be terribly good
at figuring out what might be part of an
involved disinformation campaign right
and there's all kinds of examples like
that the the more you dig into the
motivations of the speaker
um
the the the the the
more you will change how you might want
to address it and it's true of
misinformation but it's also been true
in the past of things like hate speech
right i mean there's a lot of people out
there who are
hateful people who are dedicated to it
they're white supremacists nothing
you're going to do short of banning them
is going to work
right
there are other people who are teens who
are trying to transgress and get a
thrill and if you just remind them hey
we're paying a little bit of attention
they cease entirely
right and so this is not a
one-size-fits-all environment um and and
and what works is often a product of the
motivations and the identity of the
speaker um the last thing i'll say is
that at that same center
we've worked on some computational
modeling techniques i should say this is
not my own work um it's joe about
coleman and and colleagues
modeling
what the interventions do on twitter and
one of the takeaways from that paper
which um you know it's an excellent
paper i would look it up um is that
often it takes actually multiple
different
uh interventions in order to damp down
uh the the the proliferation of
misinformation on an ecosystem so i also
think we need to be talking a little bit
about when it's not just one thing not
only does not only is one size fit not
fit all but often you're talking about
two or three different interventions on
top of one another and i'll stop there
thank you yeah um sarita we we wanted to
bring you into this conversation because
of
the way your work has been thinking
about
how how the users are treated by these
um interventions and how they could be
and we've heard sort of
why these tactics might make sense for
the platforms that are in a tough
situation trying to intervene in sort of
moving targets and and why um from a
kind of like here's a harm we might want
to like invest in you know reducing it
in this not a simple thing what how if
we approach this and think about users
and think about an ethics of care
um how do these tactics look from your
perspective
yeah and
ryan's comment around digging into kind
of the motivations of the speaker
is a really nice segue
so i'll kind of expand on that a couple
days ago i went to this panel called
then and now 50 years after attica it
was a panel people who had expertise in
incarceration and prison systems and
they were reflecting on kind of
you know the past 50 years of prison
systems um i feel like we can learn a
lot from
judicial and kind of carceral systems in
the us but it's not really like happy
lessons so it's kind of
you look at those systems and we've
spent you know decades or centuries
trying to create safe and whole
communities but we
still struggle to do that and i think
it's pretty similar online so we have
these online governance systems but they
it's not clear they're in kind of users
and communities best interests a lot of
the time
and so i you know i would say that
they're overly punitive um which is this
banning content
ban users and i'm not i think it's okay
like punishment is okay so i'm not
opposed to that um sometimes that's what
you need but the problem is that those
those responses don't kind of allow
opportunities for accountability
or correction or repair so you know ryan
gave the example of say the teenager
maybe post something that they shouldn't
have on instagram
or you might have a mom of a baby who
posts a naked picture of the baby on
facebook and it gets removed and then
you also have you know donald trump or
whoever inciting violent behaviors on
twitter and
right now you kind of have this same set
of
responses and trajectories for all those
cases even though just they're
dramatically different they should be
met with different responses so
um so this you know the
one-size-fits-all argument i'd really
agree with and i think a focus on
user behavior
instead of or at least on top of a focus
on just moderating content would um
help a lot so you kind of move away from
like this whack-a-mole governance
towards
ideas about accountability repairing
harms and you know not everyone will do
that of course um sometimes like i said
just ban them punish them it's okay
um but people make mistakes i think we
could do more to encourage better
behavior whether it's saying hey here's
why you made the mistake which is seemed
very obvious even our judicial systems
offline say here's what you did and
here's your sentencing and you don't
really
get that you know most people don't know
why why they were
why their content was removed or why
someone else's was or wasn't um
and then so you might educate them
provide more transparency um
and then maybe even sometimes ideas like
apologies or communication or mediation
in some context where there's maybe some
community norms and some commitment to
those communities
could help have other pathways beyond
just
going straight to banning the content
removing the content or banning the
users
should we ask a couple of questions yeah
thank you yeah please
have you got one to start
i do um so i think one of the things
that i'd like to know from you all is
whether you think we have enough
information on these different tactics
that aren't just going straight to the
punitive
measures that serena mentioned
so we are kind of as an industry
experimenting
but do we know
whether these things actually work um
we'll have seen you know instagram tried
hiding likes um as an experiment they
were fairly open that it wasn't very
clear whether that was having an effect
or not um
should we still experiment as an
industry with things like that even if
we're not sure that they're effective
i can go first with that i think the
answer is yes but to sarita's point
earlier i think we need to understand
what what success what what we mean by
success right um i think one of the
challenges in a lot of these decisions
is
folks are often a little unclear on okay
well what's the end goal here right is
the end goal a reduction of offline harm
that's a little difficult to measure is
it a reduction of number of user reports
well that's an easier one to measure but
there's all kinds of other ways you can
influence that right so i think it you
know even starting out with that you
have to decide you know sort of based on
your values as a company and your values
within the product you know what is it
you're actually trying to achieve but
then yes i think there has to be room
for experimentation because we're not
going to know i think the important
thing is that we are transparent about
that experimentation
ryan can you point to some that in your
studies or the research that you've seen
that some of these techniques you think
have demonstrated some effectiveness
that the kind of effectiveness is always
asking about
or is it still kind of
an ongoing object of study
oh oh sure i mean you know um
there have been in for example the
european hate speech context there have
been
no i wouldn't necessarily say
um experiments per se but what i would
say is that if there are organizations
out there that are trying to reduce the
amount of hate speech in europe right
and so to to assess their efficacy
um to show to show that that um
that they're making a change they will
keep you know some pretty good records
of what happens and there was one
experiment that involved um this wasn't
sort of a much
a much less sort of channel the
less algorithmically sort of driven
ecosystem but one in which there were
just these chat rooms and people were
comments and people would make comments
on a particular platform
and they made an arrangement wherein
um they would
get the isp or get the host to send a
note and the content of the note would
just say look here's what you said and
once and and when you said that uh
that's in violation not only of the
terms of service of this community but
also you know law because in some cases
in europe things are illegal we don't
we're not going to have that lever here
in terms of
in terms of uh being able to police
content um largely you have to be doing
something rather egregious and
transgressive for for it not to be
visible to the first amendment um and
they found enormous rates of success
where there was not repeat offenses
right and so i think you have um i think
that you have uh the possibility that
that companies will do
their own testing a b testing and other
testing
i agree with charlotte needs to be
deeply transparent i'm especially
worried about something tarleton alluded
to earlier which is the idea that um
you're you're subtly modulating
people's reach
um and i think there's already a sense
among a lot of users that um they're
they're um
you know it's almost like having a good
or a bad hair day i don't i don't have
either of those anymore but i mean it's
like having a good or a bad hair day one
day all of a sudden something you say on
twitter that you think is going to be
reaching everybody goes nowhere another
day some random thing you say and you
start to wonder is this about the
content is about or is there something
going on in the background and i think
that leads to a sense of distrust and
unease that is not healthy so i think
that transparency is critically
important we also of course saw um
facebook get sanctioned for some of its
work on emotional responses to different
kinds of content because it wasn't it
wasn't above the table that it felt it
just felt odd to people um and the other
thing i think is critically critically
important here and this is a legal point
is that we need to protect the people
that are either blowing whistles or
whistleblowers within the company or the
people that are doing external um
uh accountability research right to
determine whether or not a stated
intervention is actually effective and
one of the things that really concerns
me and others in the community is the
idea that a company would for example
weaponize
their terms of service through something
like the computer fraud and abuse act
and go around suing people who are
trying to determine whether or not
there's bad content on the site and i
think that the law should be crystal
clear that if you're doing
accountability research to look for bias
look for toxic content look for missing
look look for validation that a company
is doing what it says it's doing you
know that really should be off limits
for for um
for civil sanction um and so you know
yes i i do think experimentation is is
critical but it should be transparent
and um it shouldn't be
um it shouldn't be rained in or policed
by the company themselves yeah
let me pick up uh
on what ryan was just saying because i
you know when we started out there seems
to be a real appeal to some of these
techniques right there's a kind of
flexibility in them that's responsive to
the kind of problems that we know are
sort of always moving
um there's a gentleness to them right
that avoids the kind of
the the end the end of the speech all
together when it's removed um but but
ryan raised one
real concern here which is that it's
uh
that especially because we're trying out
these techniques they can be uh not so
public and uh you know it leaves users
in the place that ryan is describing
where they may not know why things are
happening and that breeds a lot of
suspicion so let me push that further
and kind of say like
not only are some of these techniques
um you could you could imagine platforms
not being public about them but they're
awfully hard to be transparent about
right so let let's take two examples
because some are quite visible right you
put a fact check on a tweet or you you
put an age barrier on content you can at
least see it it's happened the
fingerprints of the intervention are
there for the user who's involved for
for a researcher but let's take two so
one is
reducing something through
recommendations the example that both
charlotte and i mentioned
taking some borderline content and just
saying this is not going to travel as
far you can still get to it but it maybe
it's you know it's
the the bad tweet day that ryan was
talking about it just
doesn't go anywhere right um
it's it's hard to know how far it should
have gone so how do you understand that
it's happened and how do you be
transparent about what was done because
the idea that that video or that post
didn't go very far compared to what and
then let's ask a second one which is a
different kind of question sarita's
talking about
uh you're talking about kind of
maybe stepping towards much more sort of
uh involved interventions taking
situations where there could be some
restorative justice there could be steps
taken those are time intensive they
happen very specifically and they're
private too right if some platform is
trying to help you and i resolve
attention that isn't something that they
can exactly sort of like
list as something they're doing so so
how do we deal with these kind of um
deeper problems of transparency where
it's not clear you can be
or we haven't at least invented a way to
do it how do we deal with that
kind of problem yeah it would be nice to
have a set of
criteria that one is evaluating on and
so you know you imagine what are the
outcomes or the dependent variables call
it what you want so you know ryan
mentioned do they do it again like
classic recidivism measure you know
there could be deterrence of other
people do other people see some set of
things happen and decide to
behave differently you know there's been
studies of that on reddit but you could
also imagine other kinds of community
values like does someone who experiences
harm harassment whatever do they come
back or do they leave the community like
that's a pretty good measure of did
whatever you do make them feel safe or
comfortable coming back and that's
measurable it's much more measurable on
online than offline
um
i think the second thing would be
centering you know human rights or civil
rights in any of these kinds of
experiments or techniques and thinking
of
a nice paper by brandeis marshall on
algorithmic misogynoir which is
basically alger the kind of
anti-black misogyny it's the
baileys concept and she is saying you
know there's shadow banning and
and these things and a number of people
pointed out
the
the experience of being shadow band or
certainly the perception but it's really
hard to know on tick-tock and things
like that um
and so i think centering
the values we care about you know around
bias around race and gender in
evaluating any of these so it's not just
do people recidivate or do they come
back but it's who's
doing that and from a civil rights
perspective you might focus especially
on you know our groups that are
maybe already harmed in whatever context
being further armed by this then that's
even if overall looks good if those
groups are being further harmed then
this is not
probably the right step
charlotte
i think that's exactly right and i think
you know the point especially about
focusing not just on you know offender
behavior
but focusing on you know the
either the the follow-up behavior of the
people who felt
um you know wronged or were wronged in
that scenario or in general you know
people who maybe have never you know
filed a report or made a complaint but
you're able to understand that they
might have had a bad experience and
understanding sort of going forward you
know what what does that look like for
their experience with your product i
mean i think the the product i would or
the point i was going to come out with
originally was just you know an
observation that
you know charlton to your point earlier
it can be very difficult to know exactly
what's happening um and i think that's
like an easy thing to say well yeah
obviously these systems are complex but
you know certainly
something i have observed
universally in my time in intact you
know with with any size of company but
especially when
you are you know small to medium and
you're moving you're moving fast and all
these things are happening
employees are going in and out engineers
are going in and out you know all
different experiments are right you're
running 100 experiments at the same time
and that's not to say like and that's
the way it should always be and it's
okay if we never know what's happening
but it really is incredibly difficult to
know often exactly what part of the
system is affecting which outcome um you
know and even you know going into like
well what happened does someone ever
come
who turns out of the system
right no okay they might turn out of the
system because they had a bad experience
and certainly i've had teams where
that's exactly what we've looked at
we've said oh you know
this person reported a piece of content
or they you know
had to block someone did they cut you
know did they churn out and the data no
matter sort of how we positioned it over
years
was always super unclear because people
leave services for all kinds of reasons
and so i think all of all of those
things are really important
sort of angles to be analyzing and we
also are going to have to be okay with
like maybe we're not going to know
sometimes maybe we're not going to a lot
of the times and that's where it comes
back to i think a lot of the companies
need to be examining like what are our
values here and what are the effects we
are trying to have and that's where i
think society should be really brought
in and be partnering as well right it's
not just also about what platforms want
it's about you know what is good for us
as a human society and i think that's
where those perspectives have to come in
it's just difficult because this is a
world where we really try as much as
possible to operate on data and
ironically there's a lot of data out
there it's just not maybe readable and
that's that's one of the i think really
hard for certainly for me one of the
hard truths of the field
i i just want to add a quick point if i
may yeah um zoe and tara
you know i i think um sometimes
sometimes this sort of thing boils down
really
just picking up on something charlotte
said to political will
right i mean so for example if
if the way to address
um
disinformation campaigns from abroad
is less about
you know
um this or that particular warning or
throttling or shadow betting whatever
happens to be um
uh then uh then
and more about you know state statecraft
and economic sanctions and so on it
really takes the government to intervene
in that instance right and if we and if
we really expect a lot of of companies
um and we want them to operate in an
environment where they they can't do the
thing that they're doing unless they're
able to get a handle on the toxicity and
the environment again these are these
are somewhat matters of political will
so i think we need to focus not just on
the fact that there's a bunch of tools
we should use them all we should think
about who they're appropriate for we
also once we figure that toolkit out we
need the political will to force people
actually to deploy it in practice
well ryan i have a follow-up question
for you i guess what do you think is the
role of government here in terms of the
tactics that we're talking about because
already they're looking to legislate
industry in terms of what we do what our
practices are what our processes are how
transparent we are about setting
policies and enforcing them
but they haven't really gotten to this
um second order of action which is
demotion which is interstitials which is
warning screens and all these types of
things do you think there is a role for
government to have oversight there or or
is that
um perhaps a step too far i i want to be
clear that i'm just you know speaking
idiosyncratically about my own views um
but what i what i will do is i'll invoke
a second distinction we think about a
lot of the center which is the
distinction between speech and action or
inaction and the law should not pick
winners and losers in terms of speech
and the law should not treat platforms
like as though they were the speakers
and i don't think we should actually do
a lot about that law that says that
platforms shouldn't be viewed as the
speakers um but that doesn't mean that
we can't um ensure accountability in
other ways so for example in the context
of cyber security
we expect adequate security
and although there do exist standards
for security and best practices it's not
like the government sits down and says
you have to do x y and z and d right but
rather you're going to be held
accountable if given your scale you
don't have adequate security and there
too
the the perpetrators the problem makers
are not the companies per se it's
somebody else who's coming into the
ecosystem um and and causing harm and
yet we expect our tech uh platforms to
be resilient against that right so i
think we need to move to a place where
there's accountability without picking
winners and losers in speech and without
treating platforms as though they are
the speaker
yeah there seems to be real tension
between
the need for
the platforms that actually have the
levers to have some flexibility in
responding to things that change like
security
um the desire for some kind of
consistency and accountability
and then a sort of regulatory framework
that can both like impose those
expectations
and leave some room for that kind of
experimentation so those techniques can
grow as well
that's a that's a tricky that's a tricky
balance
i'm noticing that we have about two
minutes left and so what i was hoping to
do was finish with a quick fire round
this is research summit and so one of
the things i want to highlight is that
um there's a lot we don't know here
right this is
platforms reaching in new territories
the law reaching new territories uh
communities reaching new territories and
and we can tell that like this is a
widely uh used set of techniques if we
draw a big circle around them so i
wonder if each of you would take sort of
max 30 seconds and say what do you think
is the next thing that you wish we knew
from a research perspective that we
don't know yet like if we're going to
include this as part of the big picture
of the content moderation ecosystem and
you could send off a researcher right to
like answer a question what do you think
is the next thing that we need to
to think about or that we'd love to
answer that you don't think we have an
answer to
if i call on someone first you're like
the first person who has to jump in and
if you can make a horse reference that'd
be great because we've seen the horse
theme
i i was going to jump in until you asked
for horses but um yeah
outside of the horses
so one thing that from
the perspective of kind of justice and
accountability frameworks i would love
to have not just one but like a team a
cabal of like fantastic students from
various
places around the world countries
languages around the world where
the harms
shame
the justice theories what what their
online experiences look like and what
would be restorative for them could be
better understood and centered
beyond kind of the silicon valley ideas
of free speech
and um you know what we center in the us
awesome charlotte
the first quick answer
yeah
for me it would be
understanding what interventions
work best for the user and also work
best for the moderator moderators are in
general
uh the least well paid um and have the
least power in the overall ecosystem
when it comes to who is employed by all
of these companies and they do some of
the hardest work and so under having a
better scientific understanding of the
impact that this work has on them and
their lives would be tough for me yeah
thank you for that ryan last thought oh
i'll just quickly say you know i'd
really like to understand what
reasonableness looks like in this
context you know as a torch professor i
spend two or three days with my students
on what's reasonable behavior what
should we really expect in these
different and i think this that we're
very far from from knowing um what
constitutes not just best practice or
but what is a
like a reasonable way to address this
and i think once we get that um we'll
we'll have a better sense of what
standards should be applied that's great
thank you those are excellent questions
i'm really glad i got to hear from all
of you uh we have to close thank you so
much sarita charlotte ryan uh zoe of
course and uh and to microsoft research
for hosting um thanks i look forward to
talking to more about this in the near
near future thank you
thank you